- Leonard Chapman
Stanislav Gobert off David Gasperi
and I'm sorry David Gasparian
and so he'll Issa so he'll he saw the
Academy presents a scientific and
engineering award for the Hydra scope
please come up on the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true it was a lifetime dream I
would like to thank the Academy for the
recognition of the Hydra scope
telescopic crane it's a true honor the
concept for the Hydra scope came from
the need to achieve shots in any
environment the robust design had
inherent benefits making it waterproof
alone to capture shots from land air or
water rain or shine we're always
striving to provide filmmakers with more
creative freedom to achieve the shots
they envisioned a special thank to all
the grips key grips camera operators GPS
and technicians for all their feedback
thank you to my entire team chapman
leonard and special thanks to david
Gasparian Stas Goro Tov and Sam he saved
for their contribution and finally to my
family and beautiful wife Cindy thank
you for all your love and support thank
you very much
I'd like to say thank you Academy for
this prestigious award and say thank you
to my beautiful wife who support me my
parents who give me love and support and
especially I would like to dedicate this
award to my father who was teaching me
and bring to that level thank you I'd
like to thank all Chapman Leonard
employees to make all this happen
impossible for us to be right here also
I'd like to thank my wife sister family
and God bless you thank you I like to
thank the Academy and we'll be honor for
us to be here today from you guys thank
you very much thank you for Lana Chapman
and the group teamwork thank you to my
wife and have a good evening
thank you
[Applause]